use the graph below to decide which of
the following equations are true so
before i even look at these equations
let's think about what's going on here
so i have a line
and then they we've defined all of these
right triangles where the hypotenuse of
the right triangles are are the line and
you could view this you could view this
right triangle say this one in red as
really side c is our change in y our
vertical changes we go from this point
to this point and side and side d right
over here is our horizontal change
notice we go d to the right and then we
go c up
if you're starting at this point and
going to that point side b is your
horizontal change and side a is your
vertical change and the one thing we
know about lines is if you construct
these right triangles like this your
change in y over your change in x the
ratio between those two is always going
to be constant we call that ratio the
slope we also know that these are going
to be similar triangles that the ratio
between corresponding sides is going to
be the same so these are obviously right
triangles these are horizontal lines
these are vertical lines and all of
these are similar triangles and the
ratio and because they're all similar
the ratio between this vertical side and
this base right over here is always
going to be the same so for example we
know that the ratio of a to b
is going to be equal to the ratio of c
to d
of c
now let's work through some of this
other stuff right over here so they say
y plus 1 over x plus 2 is equal to the
ratio of a to b let's see if that's
right
so this is the point x comma y
so what's y plus one
well y plus one is literally the same
thing as the length c right over here
notice this height let me do this in a
new color
this height right over here
this is y
but then if you add one you get all the
way
down here so this right over here is y
plus one
y plus one and then this base
this base right over here
once again you see this is x plus two
this length
this length right over here let me see
if you can see it this length right over
here that is x you start you start at x
equals zero you go two or it looks like
two to the right but you go x to the
right and you get right over there but
if you want to get all the way over here
you have to you have to add two so this
right over here is x
plus two
and we know the ratio of this height to
this base right over here is always
going to be the same
so the ratio of y plus 1
to x plus 2
to x plus 2 is going to be equal to
the ratio of c to d
of c to d which is the same thing as the
ratio as a to b
as a to b
now that's what they're saying right
here y plus 1 over x plus 2 needs to be
equal to a over b y plus 1 over x plus 2
needs to be equal to a over b
so that one's right
here here they've swapped them they've
swapped the two and then now they're
mixing a and d together now this is kind
of a strange thing that they're doing
looking at the ratio of a to d you could
swap these two you could swap these two
and say well what's the ratio of x plus
two to y plus 1 going to be
if this ratio is always constant then
the inverse ratio or say the reciprocal
ratio is always going to be constant as
well
we could call that 1 over the slope so
what
so x plus 2 over y plus 1 would be need
would need to be equal to the reciprocal
of this which would be d over c which
would be the reciprocal of this of or b
over a
do we see that here no they've mixed it
all up they've mixed the a and the d
together x plus 2 over y plus 1 is not
the same thing as a over d we're not
even using corresponding sides we're
mixing up triangles so this is not the
case
now they say y over x
y the ratio of y over x needs to be the
same as the ratio of c over d so what's
y over x
so y
y is
this length right over here
that what i did in black
that is y
i don't want to cover anything else and
what is x x is
x is this length
right over here so that you could
construct a right triangle that looks
something like this but notice it's hype
this is x right over here it's
hypotenuse does not it's not the its
hypotenuse is not the line the x is not
going from it's not essentially our
change in x between some starting point
and some ending point we're starting at
the origin and we're getting 2xy it has
a different hypotenuse than the actual
line so this triangle is not similar to
all of these other triangles so the
ratio of y over x is not going to be the
same as the ratio as c over d
so this is not going to be the case if
this line went through the origin then
maybe we could we could talk a little
further about that but this is
definitely not going to be the case
now let's look at this
c over d the ratio of this entire height
and i know i'm using too many colors
right here it's hard to see so c is this
entire length the ratio of c
to d
so this is our slope the ratio of our
rise over our run the ratio of our
change in y over our change in x so the
ratio of c to d is the same is equal to
a
over b well that's that's the definition
of our slope this ratio is constant when
we're dealing with the line so this is
this is definitely true now let's
actually input it into the exercise and
make sure that we got it
so we have actually that's not the
exercise there we have that one and we
have that one and we can check our
answer and we got it right